Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Cinnabon in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, Cinnabon's classic rolls come
in four portion sizes: as a single,
as a two-pack, as a four-pack,
and our largest size,
a six-pack.
In the US, Cinnabon classic rolls
come in three sizes: the single —
oh, my God.
I want to eat this so bad.
Then you got the four-pack,
for you and, let's be honest, just you,
and then you can get yourself a six-pack.
This has some weight to it.
Cinnabon in the US also
offers catering sizes
that you can't get in the UK.
That means we can also get
our classic Cinnabon rolls
in a nine-pack catering tray.
Put that on the screen! Oh!
That's 50% larger than
the UK's biggest pack.
Oh, amazing.
But is there a difference in the size
of the rolls themselves?
We're going to weigh a classic Cinnabon
in both countries to find out.
You can get BonBites in
the UK, but unfortunately
the store I went to didn't
have them this morning.
If you can get them, then they should come
in a pack of four.
In the US, you can get BonBites
in a pack of four, 16,
or the catering tray of 36.
This is nine times bigger
than the UK's four-pack.
[thunder rumbles]
[laughs maniacally]
Four? Get a life.
UK Cinnabons also offer MiniBons.
These come in three portion sizes:
as a single, as a six-pack,
or our largest size, as a 15-pack.
Use these as, like, a doorstop.
I think they're stale.
[box thuds]
Over here, our MiniBons come in portions
of one, nine, 15,
and, of course, we have
a catering tray of 20.
What about the drinks?
In the UK, we can get
hot drinks in two sizes:
as a regular, which is 12 fluid ounces,
or a large, which is 16 fluid ounces.
In the US, our hot beverages
come in four sizes:
small, regular, large,
and this big catering bag.
Or does it?
[whooshes]
Because they forgot those three.
The more observant among
you would've noticed
that the UK's large is
only the regular over here.
We can also get iced drinks in the UK,
but they just come in the same sizes
as our hot drinks, 12 and 16 ounces.
The sizes change a little when you choose
the iced drinks in the US.
We got the small and the regular
and the catering size.
Again, the more observant
of you would notice
that there are some beverages
missing from this cup.
"Joe must've started
drinking them earlier."
Nuh-uh. Had a major
beverage-spilling mishap
with the delivery here.
Ah, more on that later.
The final things to compare
are the toppings and sauces.
In the UK, you can get
some additional toppings,
like the cream cheese and the pecans,
and they just come in the
one size, these little cups.
In the US, we can get extra frosting
as a regular side of the
cream-cheese frosting,
I mean, a whole pint of the frosting,
a side of pecans, who cares?
Let's weigh the largest frosting side
in each country to find the difference.
[laughs] That just, like, barely moved.
So this is eight of their frostings.
Soon to be seven.
It's described as "cream cheese ambient."
Cream cheese ambient.
That sounds like a really
experimental music genre.
It's pretty cool, you probably
wouldn't have heard of it,
but yeah, no, I listen to
mostly cream cheese ambient.
Here are all the Cinnabon
items from the UK
that you won't find in the US.
Here's everything on a Cinnabon menu
you will not find in the UK.
To start off with, we
have some Bon varieties
you actually won't find in the US.
Let's start down here with ChocoBons.
So, as far as I can tell, ChocoBons are
pretty much just the standard rolls,
maybe with a little
bit of chocolate powder
sprinkled into the mix, but then also
they are covered in chocolate sauce.
Cheers.
Our next exclusive roll
is a Lotus Biscoff Bon.
Longtime viewers of
the show will know that
I don't really like Lotus Biscoff.
I didn't realize how
passionately the crew felt
about Lotus Biscoff, because
I'm now taking heat for this.
Apparently it's because
I don't like coffee
and they're really good with coffee.
I just drink tea, so
maybe it's wasted on me.
Again, look, you do you, it's fine,
just not for me. Too sweet for me.
And then finally, because
we're actually shooting this
on Valentine's Day, we can get
a limited-edition Valentine's Bon.
All of our exclusive Bons
can also be purchased
in all three forms, which
is the regular size,
the BonBites, and the MiniBons.
We actually don't have any
exclusive Bons in the US.
We can only get the classic
and caramel pecan Bons,
both of which are obviously
available in the UK.
But we do have some other
exclusives to showcase.
The first one, the churro swirls.
♪ They forgot them ♪
But here's what they look like,
and I would love to have tried them.
Now, we don't have churro swirls,
but we do have something
called Cinnachips,
which are like small, crunchy
pieces of cinnamon roll.
I'm not sure if crunchy is what I want
from my cinnamon roll.
[crunching]
They are crunchy. They weren't kidding.
These aren't doing it for me.
They're really kind of dry and
a little bit burned, almost,
so you kind of get that,
like, acrid burn taste,
which cancels out pretty much any benefits
that you get from the cinnamon sugar.
[crunches loudly]
We also have something
called Center of the Roll,
which Cinnabon has trademarked in the US.
Now, here's what I'm assuming this is
by looking at it.
What it looks like,
they just took Cinnabons
and, like, mashed them up
or, like, unraveled them
and put them in a cup, and this is smart,
'cause the only thing I
think keeping everyone
from getting a Cinnabon at the mall
is it's kind of a pain in the butt to eat,
and I think Cinnabon noticed this,
and they responded with this.
Like, "You're right. We'll just rip it up,
put it in a cup, and have at it."
This works.
Well, you don't want to
mess with the classics.
If you want to
sit down, have a Cinnabon
at the food court,
go for it, but
if you're not in the mood,
just get one of these.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God, look at this.
Are kidding me with this?
This is so great.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I forgot —
oh, I forgot I'm shooting
a video right now.
This is the, that was the regular,
and this is the caramel pecan Bon.
We have a near equivalent here,
but we call it Roll-on-the-Go.
As far as I can tell, it's
pretty much just the same thing.
It's a small cup of I think
just the center pieces of cinnamon rolls.
Ours come in two flavors,
classic or choco.
I do think my favorite
part of a cinnamon roll
is the gooey middle bit.
See if this holds up.
This is pretty good.
Decent amount of frosting.
They could maybe have given
you slightly more frosting,
'cause I think there's some
drier bites in the middle. But.
Pretty good.
In the US, we also have cookie BonBites.
These are chocolate chip cookies
with cinnamon rolls inside of —
I'm just finding this out right now.
Chocolate chip cookies with
cinnamon rolls inside of them?
Yo, straight up when I saw this, I'm like,
who's getting cookies at Cinnabon?
This cannot have a cinnamon roll inside.
Oh, my God, do you see it?
It actually — what?
I didn't even know this existed!
You got that? You got that, yeah?
Yo, look at that, oh.
Look what's inside of it.
Oh, my God, that's crazy.
This cookie's pregnant with a Cinnabon.
[baby cries]
Now let's get in here.
Eh, better an idea than execution.
We also have CinnaSweeties,
which look like mini
doughnuts that I'm assuming
are cinnamon — oh, wait,
I think these have the frosting inside.
We've done these for ... Taco Bell?
The Cinnabon Delights. I'm pretty sure
this is filled with some sort
of, like, cream cheese, right?
Wait a second!
There's no --
[gasping]
There's no cream cheese
in these! They're blanks!
The UK Cinnabon website also advertises
that some of their branches will have
Carvel brand ice cream as an option,
but unfortunately, we didn't have that
at the one we went to.
Now we're on to the sauces and toppings.
In the US, we have a side of Oreo pieces
that you can get on top
of your Bon. There it is.
We also have the 8 ounces of frosting,
and we also have — grr, close.
This right here is,
you get a side of the caramel frosting.
That's also really good.
We only have the one
exclusive topping option here
in the UK, and it's this
one, the Lotus Biscoff crumb.
In the interest of fairness,
I'm going to try it again.
It's just fine. It's just fine.
Maybe with a coffee, but.
No, it's still not for me. Sorry, guys.
Next up, we got drinks.
Ah, finally. I'm dying of thirst.
We have coffee, obviously,
and you can also get
yourself a hot chocolate.
Let's check out their hot chocolate.
I mean, it looks like hot chocolate.
There's nothing to see.
Wow, actually not that good.
Blech.
Skip that.
We actually have a better
range of hot drinks in the UK,
including pretty much a full
range of espresso drinks,
including an Americano, a cappuccino,
a latte, a mocha, and so on.
We can also get a tea and a hot chocolate.
You can also customize the hot drinks
with a range of syrups,
including cinnamon spice,
toasted marshmallow,
salted caramel, and more,
although if you put any
of those in a cup of tea,
I will fight you. [boxing bell rings]
In the US, we have way more
cold drink options than hot.
Here are the following
exclusive cold drink options.
First up, cinnamon roll
cold brew iced coffee.
Another victim of the Uber driver.
Ooh! [laughs]
I'm falling apart.
Pretty good. Too sweet.
Then we got the raspberry lemonade.
Also missing 2 inches. Ubefied.
I mean, I don't want to
give the guy a bad rating,
but, like, look, I have
not sipped any of these.
Oh, my God, this raspberry,
I love it. It's great.
Shout-out to Greta Thunberg.
I'm gonna use my straw twice.
I care about the environment!
No more single-use plastic.
This is the frozen raspberry lemonade.
Whoa!
That's, like, powerful.
This is really good.
Bottle of milk.
No, thanks.
And, of course, fountain drinks,
and I'm the most bummed because
out of all the drinks that spilled —
we have so many flavors to choose from.
Let's get those on the screen.
But the one I specifically
wanted was this one,
was the Pibb Xtra.
Pibb Xtra's perfectly fine.
It's a Dr Pepper wannabe.
Back in the '90s, '97, '98, or whatever,
Mr. Pibb changed its formula to Pibb Xtra.
They're trying to get in on
Dr Pepper's market share.
It's so annoying. But the problem is,
is that there's no Mr. Pibb
anymore. [rousing music]
30 years of no Mr. Pibb. It's ridiculous!
I am using my platform right now
to talk to the executives
at Pibb Xtra or Mr. Pibb:
Release the Mr. Pibb recipe.
I'm begging you.
It doesn't have any value for you!
You're not making it, so
there's no value, right?
You're just sitting on the recipe,
you're not even making it?
It's worthless to you.
It's priceless to me.
And I don't want you people watching,
this happened last time,
people were messaging me like,
"Oh, yeah, we got Mr.
Pibb here at the Walmart."
It's like, it's Pibb
Xtra, it's not Mr. Pibb.
They're different. OK?
If anyone watching has cans
of Mr. Pibb from the '90s,
connect with me. I will buy it off of you.
I will pay for the shipping.
That stays in the video, or I quit.
We have a few exclusive cold
drinks over here in the UK,
including an iced latte,
a strawberry lemonade,
and a mango lemonade.
I got the strawberry lemonade today.
Pretty pleasant. Quite refreshing.
Also, in the UK, is it true that you guys
consider lemonade to be more like
a carbonated lemon beverage, like Sprite?
That's true, Joe. If you ask
for a lemonade in the UK,
expect something that's
carbonated and usually clear,
so more like a Sprite.
Although I will say,
Cinnabon seems to be doing it
kind of the American way,
so maybe you'd approve of that one.
Now, you can also get
something called a Chillatta
in the US and the UK.
However, over here, they come in flavors
of Oreo cookies and cream,
strawberries and cream,
which I got, and the
double chocolate mocha.
That's just OK.
Don't bother.
In the UK, Chillattas
come in five flavors:
cinnamon roll, strawberry, mango,
caramel latte, and chocolate mocha.
I got the cinnamon roll one today.
Actually looks pretty good.
It also looked even more impressive
when the whipped cream was
kind of in a nice swirl.
It's just, like, a,
again, quite sweet
but pretty, like, luxurious
cinnamony milkshake.
It certainly seems like it.
I cannot remember a time
when there wasn't one
in any mall I've gone to.
You can always smell it before you see it.
It's impossible to separate
the scent of Cinnabon
from the mall and vice versa.
It's like a soundtrack to the memory,
but how it smells,
so Cinnabon is like the
smell-track to malls.
Does that make sense?
And that's by design.
Cinnabon purposely put their locations
away from food courts
and other food stalls
so the Cinnabon odor would waft
and not interfere with any other smells.
So if you're in the
mall, you smell Cinnabon
and only Cinnabon, and that's
almost like nose marketing?
I don't know how you would describe it,
and it's really smart, right?
'Cause when you smell
it, man, you smell it,
and you're like, there it
is, I gotta have one. So.
Is Cinnabon a meal, a snack, a dessert?
I'm gonna go with snack.
I feel like one of
those regular Cinnabons,
I could just eat one of those
easily. Maybe one and a half.
I don't really know my Cinnabon limit.
I just kind of found out
about these little guys,
and I feel like I could easily
knock out half this tray.
I don't think it should be a meal,
'cause that could do
some damage to your body.
As far as a dessert, it seems weird to me
to eat a full meal and
then get a Cinnabon.
Like, it just kind of exists on its own.
So, yeah, it's weird
to consider it a snack,
but you're definitely
not having it for lunch,
and you're definitely not
having it after a meal, so.
By default, snack.
In the UK, a single Cinnabon classic roll
will cost you £2.99,
which at the time of
recording this was $3.65.
In the US, a single Cinnabon classic roll
will cost you $7.19.
That makes this single US roll
97% more expensive.
That is hilarious.
But does the price change if you bulk-buy?
A six-pack of classic rolls in the UK
will cost you £10.49,
which at the time of recording was $12.80.
So by spending three and a
half times the amount of money,
you're getting six times
the amount of Cinnabon,
which is a pretty good deal.
In the US, a six-pack of
Cinnabon classic rolls
will cost you $24.99,
so even when you are bulk-buying,
it's 95% more expensive to buy in the US.
For that same 500% increase in food,
we pay 247% more money.
It's not often on "Food
Wars" that it's much cheaper
in the UK than it is in
the US to buy fast food.
How's that feel, Joe?
Well, it's Cinnabon, and I
will pay whatever it takes.
This stuff is amazing.
They could double the
price. I'm still eating it.
The UK Cinnabon website doesn't give
a full nutritional
breakdown including things
like the fat and the
sugar content of Cinnabon.
However, when we got this CinnaPack,
I noticed that they actually have
a full breakdown on the box.
Here, we're given the information
for 100 grams' worth of
classic Cinnabon rolls.
So you might remember from earlier,
when we weighed one roll,
we found that it was pretty
much exactly 200 grams,
so doubling those numbers
gives us the stats
for a full roll in the UK.
Here's everything that's
in a classic Cinnabon roll
in the UK.
So that's almost 40% of your
daily recommended calories,
80% of your daily saturated fat,
and over 110% of your daily sugar.
To put the calories into context,
one of these rolls is like eating
three McDonald's hamburgers.
Here's everything in a classic
Cinnabon roll in the US.
You are reading that right,
61 grams of sugar.
And for some reason,
1,150 milligrams of sodium?
That puts us slightly ahead of the UK
in every single category.
I mean, look at that sodium.
That is way higher, for some reason.
That's exactly 50% of your
daily sodium in one roll.
What about some other even
more unhealthy menu items?
The most-calorific roll in the UK
is the Lotus Biscoff roll,
which clocks in at 1,019 calories.
That's a hefty increase
on the standard roll
as well as being over half of
your daily caloric allowance,
or, as we now use to quantify things,
four McDonald's hamburgers.
The least-healthy roll in the US
is the caramel pecan Bon,
which is 1,090 calories.
This is also the most calorific thing
on the entire US menu, sort of.
A single caramel pecan Bon roll
is 1,090 calories, but
according to Cinnabon,
if you get them in a pack of four or six,
the calories of each individual roll
increases to 1,160.
It is unclear why that is the case,
but I'm going to go ahead and guess
because they dump way more frosting on it.
The most-calorific thing on the UK menu
actually isn't a roll, it's this,
a 16-ounce cinnamon roll Chillatta.
One of these contains a
whopping 1,231 calories.
That means that one of these
large cinnamon roll Chillattas
combined with one of our
classic cinnamon rolls in the UK
would put you pretty much exactly
at your 2,000-calorie daily limit.
Cinnabon does not disclose
a full ingredients list
in the US, only allergens.
The website in the UK also didn't contain
ingredients information, but once again,
the box provided us with
all of the ingredients
of a classic cinnamon
roll, and it is a lot.
But are there any ingredients which
you need to look out for?
The bun itself is pretty much fine,
despite the sheer number of ingredients.
The things to watch out
for are actually found
in the frosting.
The frosting contains an
imitation vanilla extract,
which in turn contains E1520.
This is also known as propylene glycol.
It's fairly common in foods
and in small doses is used as a carrier
for ingredients which
aren't soluble in water.
However, it can be toxic in large doses.
It's one of the main
ingredients in antifreeze,
as it lowers the freezing point of water.
Too much propylene glycol could lead
to internal bleeding and kidney failure.
Mm. The good news is that you're unlikely
to ever hit these levels from food.
Just don't go drinking antifreeze.
The lemon extract in the
frosting also contains E102,
sometimes known as yellow 5 or tartrazine.
It's a somewhat controversial
yellow food dye.
It was part of a panic in
the UK about food colorings
causing hyperactivity in children,
although eventually it was shown
that there was limited evidence for this.
A 2015 study also found that yellow No. 5
can damage your white
blood cells, which, mm,
means you're likely to
develop tumors and cancer.
See us out, dancing rats.
A US Cinnabon weighs
222 grams, 2-2-2,
as in the type of diabetes
this video's going to give me.
No. 2, baby.